[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros
bienvenidos a nuestro espacio de cinco
minutos son
cinco minutos cuando perdón hoy nos
acompaña a alejandra barrios directora
de la misión de observación electoral en
colombia hablamos sobre el informe de
violencia contra los líderes sociales y
también los políticos
esta misión de observación electoral
tiene un observatorio de violencia
política que sigue entre otros los
ataques contra los diferentes tipos de
líderes y también la publica reportes de
las nos reporta lo que pasa en colombia
con respecto a eso le pregunto qué nos
puede decir entonces de la situación
actual de esta población que está siendo
atacada
pero efectivamente durante este contarte
que quiere extender toda mi solidaridad
a las víctimas del ataque que sufrió y
parís y realmente toda la compañía desde
un país que sabe qué es tener víctimas
como lo estaba señalando nosotros
hicimos un informe de cortes primer
semestre de cuál es la situación de
violencia contra líderes sociales
políticos y comunales en lo que llevamos
en este primer semestre son 242 hechos
registrados frente es de violencia
frente a cualquier tipo de liderazgo
dentro de los cuales la mitad están
dirigidos a líderes sociales les siguen
los líderes políticos que fueron
elegidos el año pasado y que empezaron
su mandato en enero de este año y
finalmente tenemos los líderes comunales
que son los líderes de la célula básica
de la democracia colombiana es decir la
de los barrios la de las veredas la de
los caseríos
ahora este más reciente reporte indica
una tendencia creciente en este tipo de
ataques le pregunto cuáles son las
razones que las razones que explican en
esta oleada en colombia' la oleada de
violencia
nosotros esperábamos que durante el
período de confinamiento estricto que tú
y bancolombia durante siete meses
ciertas semanas tuviéramos una
disminución sustancial en la violencia
contra los diferentes liderazgos y nos
encontramos que de manera particular por
los liderazgos sociales de líderes
étnicos es decir indígenas y afros los
que se han visto con afectados que puede
explicar esto que también encontramos
que durante estas fiestas semanas y en
lo que llevamos de pandemia en colombia
ha habido una expansión de los grupos
armados ilegales y eso se traduce en que
los territorios en conflictos entre los
diferentes grupos entonces grupos de
autodefensas grupos de narcotráfico de
la guerrilla para tener control
territorial no solamente tenemos los 248
hechos de violencia contra los
diferentes liderazgos sino que después
del confinamiento ha venido acompañado
de una importante número de masacres
llevamos 61 masacres que este año que lo
que está demostrando es que los
territorios especialmente los rurales
más afectados por la expansión de estos
grupos killer al lamentable la situación
que está viviendo los líderes sociales
en colombia y le pregunto entonces
siendo así si cree que el gobierno del
presidente iván duque está haciendo lo
necesario para proteger a estos líderes
sociales
mira esta no es una historia nueva en
colombia desde el 2006 que la misión de
observación electoral hace seguimiento a
la violencia contra tres tipos de
liderazgo hemos venido viendo como
estuve y baja dependiendo de ves que
estamos en el acuerdo de paz y estamos
ante un proceso electoral y de pronto se
incrementa o disminuye las economías
ilegales
el abordaje posiblemente es lo que ha
sido equivocado que están haciendo
abordajes a partir de políticas
gubernamentales y no de políticas de
estado y esas políticas gubernamentales
si bien en el nivel nacional son muy
consistentes y buscan generar
articulación entre las diferentes
entidades en el nivel local lo que
encontramos es desconfianza frente a las
instituciones del orden nacional muy
poco diálogo con las organizaciones
donde están los líderes sociales y los
líderes comunales y sobre todo muy poco
conocimiento de cuáles son las rutas
expeditas de protección nuestra
violencia se concentra especialmente en
la zona rural y es en estas zonas
donde debería tener los mejores
mecanismos de presenciar el estado que
hoy no tenemos
así es alejandra puede ser muchísimas
gracias entonces por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros en nuestro segmento de
france 24 5 minutos con que tenga usted
un feliz día era alejandra barrios
directora de la misión de observación
electoral en colombia hablando del
informe de violencia contra los líderes
sociales y políticos nos vemos en una
próxima oportunidad
[Música]